and a fox news alert out of michigan at
this
hour as articles of impeachment are
introduced against governor gretchen
whitmer there
over the state's plan to enforce more
virus-related restrictions
brand new hour here in america's
newsroom welcome i'm sandra smith hi
trace
sandra good morning to you again good
morning everyone i'm trace gallagher
three michigan house republicans filing
the resolution
arguing governor whitmer's new limits on
gatherings violate the constitutional
rights of michigan citizens among other
things
the articles also accuse her of
corruption the governor's office has
dismissed the impeachment effort saying
quote
governor whitmer doesn't have any time
for partisan politics or people who
don't wear masks
don't believe in science and don't have
a plan to fight this
virus mike tobin live in chicago on this
developing story hey mike
and sandra it's important to note right
off the top although there's a great
deal of opposition to governor gretchen
whitmer
and her handling of the pandemic this
resolution does not have universal
support from michigan republicans in
fact
the leadership in both the state house
and the senate do not support it
lee chatfield the republican speaker of
the house told our fox affiliate
the resolution is a distraction from
what needs to be done in the state mike
shirkey the senate majority leader
says he has not signed on to the
resolution however three republicans in
the house representatives beau le fave
der rendon and matt murdock
introduced the resolution arguing that
governor whitmer should be removed from
office for corrupt conduct crimes and
misdemeanors
part of the resolution reads she has
exceeded her constitutional authority
violated the constitutional rights of
the people of michigan issued orders
that are not in the best interests of
the people of the state and use the
pandemic as an opportunity
to reward political allies the
resolution argues that whitmer bypassed
the legislature with executive orders
ban free exercise of religion
offered no-bid contracts to political
allies and failed to manage the crisis
now whitmer has come under fire for the
harsh and critics say arbitrary nature
of the lockdowns in michigan
the wolverine state just extended the
shutdown for three weeks
whitmer used the word pause one of the
authors of the resolution matt murdock
reportedly said that
was the tipping point it should be noted
that michigan has seen a 29
increase in coronavirus cases over the
past week
sandra mike tobin thank you